You are now ready to think about one
of my favorite basic parallel computing
problems, the problem of list ranking.
It's a notoriously hard problem to
speed up which is what makes it fun.
And along the way to parallelizing it,
I think you'll get a lot of insight into
the differential between sequential and
parallel computing.
Now suppose I give you a collection of
values stored as a singly linked list
with a head pointer.
The list ranking problem asks for the
distance of every node from the head.
So for example, for this list,
we compute the following values.
The head is a distance of zero away
from itself, so it gets a zero.
Its successor gets a one,
its successor gets a two, and so on.
Sequentially, this
problem is super easy.
Start at the head, maintain a counter,
and walk the list.
To be more precise,
here's pseudo code for an algorithm.
Notice what it does?
It maintains a counter, starts at the
head, and it iterates over the rest of
the nodes, storing the rank, and
updating the rank as it goes.
Now, I want you to stop and
think about this for a second.
How the heck would you parellelize this?
In principle, I'll claim that this
problem is sort of like a scan.
Can you see how?